just saying that you can't be sure that
it wasn't you that's ridiculous of
course it wasn't me
marijuana is a memory lost drug so maybe
you just don't remember i would remember
well how could you if it just erased
your memory that's not how it works now
how do you know how it works
plenty of classic tv comedies have made
viewers laugh and maybe even taught them
a thing or two about life friendship
love and the classic rock stylings of
jessie and the rippers
okay that last one was mostly full house
but i mean if people liked the show
right still only a few series have
really changed the game messed around
with our basic conception of what a tv
show could be and how it could engage
with viewers on this episode of rt
essentials we're taking a look at some
of the most innovative and influential
comedy series of all time shows that
fundamentally altered the tv landscape
and paved the way for the next
generation of creative minds
and speaking of game changing we have a
special announcement to make right here
right now unlike the typical rt
essentials list which are based on our
editorial pieces you can find on our
website rottentomatoes.com this
episode's list is based on a section of
our brand new book for all of you
television completists out there
introducing
do you not have a drum roll okay just
run the graphic rotten tomatoes the
ultimate binge guide with 296 must-see
shows that change the way we watch tv
not only is it a fascinating look into
the evolution of tv through engaging
series write-ups infographics and deep
dive essays we see it as a challenge a
bingeable bucket list of the shows you
just have to see before you die broken
down into fun sections like classics
that made the molds and those that broke
them mysteries and mine i'm not allowed
to say that reality tv and docu-series
that captured the zeitgeist and much
more the ultimate binge guide is
available for pre-order now and will be
released in november so make sure to
grab one because there really isn't any
better companion for the season couch
potato and the novice alike
and with that a reminder that the
spoiler alert is in effect here and
let's get on with the greatest
game-changing tv comedies
[Music]
can't be you and kramer are
flying over the andes
why are we flying over the andes we got
a soccer game in chile anyway the plane
crashes who are you going to eat to
survive
kramer
so fast
what about me nah
1990s favorite seinfeld is today
remembered as a show about nothing a
classic bit of dialogue from a meta
storyline in which the characters
pitched a sitcom to nbc but that's not
really how actual creators jerry
seinfeld and larry david described their
original concept to nbc executives their
pitch which they brought to the network
way back in 1988 focused on how a
comedian comes up with this material and
the answer from his wacky neighbor in
keeping with the pitch a lot of the
show's elements were borrowed from
seinfeld and david's real lives ninny
you're missing it it's higher
eyelash make a wish i don't want to
make a wish okay
didn't come true
the character of kramer is based on an
actual former neighbor of larry david's
named kenny kramer he was queasy at
first about letting them use his real
surname in the show so during
pre-production the character was
referred to as chressler well yeah it
seems weird now but you probably would
have gotten used to it cressler feldman
they all really work but thankfully the
real kramer relented and took home a
tidy one thousand dollars as a thank you
from the production i mean look they
didn't know he's gonna be a hit
i was handcuffed to the bed
in my underwear
where i remained for she certainly
seemed interested in me
though she was attractive she was also
in fact
a nazi
a former classmate of jerry's named
michael costanza claimed to be the real
world inspiration behind jason
alexander's character george and even
sued the production for a hundred
million dollars claiming they'd violated
his privacy the creators argued that
george was inspired by larry david
personally not the guy who happened to
be named costanza
seinfeld has been regularly ranked
amongst the best tv shows of all time by
a whole slew of publications from
entertainment weekly to rolling stone to
tv guide the writers guild of america
called it the second best written show
of all time behind only the sopranos
plus seinfeld actually had you know an
ending so extra points
and if 68 emmy nominations and 10 wins
doesn't sell you on its lasting
influence consider that it has remained
among the most popular sitcoms on
streaming platforms to this very day i
mean look i love you for what's on the
inside
i love you cause you're so wonderful
[Music]
well be careful that's real hair the
original concept behind the fresh prince
of bel air was inspired by the life of
record executive benny medina who grew
up in a poor neighborhood in east los
angeles but moved into the beverly hills
mansion of a wealthy friend's family as
a teenager medina and his business
partner jeff [ __ ] pitched the concept
to iconic producer quincy jones who in
turn brought it to nbc at around the
same time purely by coincidence medina
met rapper will smith at a taping of the
arsenio hall show smith was reluctant to
star in a sitcom as he'd only had one
acting role in his life to date as a
t-shirt salesman in an abc after school
special
i'm sure he was riveting though i mean
you really did believe he wanted to sell
you those t-shirts
the money however was too tempting to
pass up as young will had already gotten
into some tax trouble with the irs
following the runaway success of his
first album you know the one with dj
jazzy jeff hey jazz i guess sometimes
you have to get jiggy in an affordable
budget conscious way but uh he's still
jake
[Music]
uncle phil please do you mind turning
the music back on i'm trying to study
will smith and quincy jones also
collaborated on the show's iconic theme
song which is formally titled yo home to
bel air by the way and it's been rumored
online that the cab driver seen in the
opening credits was played by quincy
jones himself but that's just an urban
legend folks in fact the real quincy
jones never learned to drive a car
nbc hired writers andy and susan
borowitz yes the same andy borowitz who
writes those new yorker columns to work
on the pilots so they're listed today as
the show's creators the character of
carlton was named after a good friend of
andy's carlton hughes who went on to
co-create shows like lost and bates
motel
actor alfonzo ribeiro based his famous
carlson dance on two key inspirations
courtney cox and bruce springsteen
getting down in the dancing in the dark
video and eddie murphy doing what he
called the white man dance in his
hilarious stand up special delirious
he kicked you out of the house
well he didn't actually kick her out of
the house he just changed all the locks
and told her she didn't live there
anymore
and for all you millennials who want to
learn how to do the carlton just go back
here and up here back here
and up here back here quicker forward
quicker you see how it works and i'm
never invited to a wedding again
sometimes i would buy vogue instead of
dinner
i just felt it fed me more his word said
no but his kiss said yes died men we
have to run to helga the hot waxer every
other week but them how would they like
it if we told them to shape their heads
trim their trunk plant their bulbs a lot
of the shows we're looking back on took
a while to find their audience but not
hbo sex in the city which was a mega hit
right out of the gate and one of the
network's highest rated first year shows
in history it remained popular
throughout its run from june of 1998
through february of 2004 taking home
seven emmy awards including one each for
stars sarah jessica parker and cynthia
nixon sex in the city was the very first
cable show in history to win the emmy
for outstanding comedy series you see
back in this era network tv continued to
dominate award season it was also the
only hbo comedy to win the top prize at
the emmys until 2015 when deep started
its string of best comedy wins i love
you too richard
but i love me more and i will not be
judged by you or society
i will wear whatever and whomever i want
as long as i can breathe and kneel but
beyond just the red carpet the show and
its costume designer patricia field had
a major impact on women's fashion around
the turn of the millennium the new york
times credited the series with inspiring
trends around name plate necklaces
manalo blahnik shoes flower corsages and
visible bra straps plus the general
practice of combining hot couture and
fast fashion pieces within a single
outfit but again that's only if you're a
carry there's totally different rules
for mirandas i'm sorry i didn't write
them i i said no white no ivory no
nothing that says virgin i have a child
the jig is up sex in the city is also
credited with massively increasing the
popularity of the cosmopolitan cocktail
the main foursomes drink of choice the
pink colored cosmo was first developed
in the 1930s but only became a mainstay
on modern bar menus after fans
obsessively watched samantha jones knock
them down and who's gonna blame him
she's hashtag goals if i worried what
everybody in new york was saying about
me i'd never lived the house the series
was based on a 1997 book by author
candace bushnell compiling columns she'd
written for the new york observer these
comments were inspired by her real life
and some of the characters are stand-ins
for real people mr big for example was
modeled after a real guy named ron
golotti that bushnell dated for about a
year after meeting him at a party in
1995 and i'm sure he looked exactly like
chris noth too i'm not even going to
google it i believe it and that's what
counts i thought by the time i got here
i'd know what to say
and
well you're late
the party's over
i'll say it
but bushnell was quick to insist that
she's not the real carrie bradshaw and
it is a persona she created to distance
herself from the columns even kerry's
apartment in the show isn't completely
authentic the series claims that carrie
lives in a swanky neighborhood on the
upper east side but all the exteriors
were shot at 66 perry street in the west
village
is there nothing left to believe in
anymore
[Music]
will what are you doing i think you've
sprung a leak
what are you talking about
i haven't been with a woman in some time
but i'm pretty sure they're not supposed
to do that the groundbreaking nbc sitcom
will and grace was created by real-life
friends max muchnick and david cohan
based on their actual friendship with
casting agent janet eisenberg max had
first met eisenberg while they were
rehearsing a play at age 13. he later
worked with cohen in shows including
dream on remember dream on and boston
common and the three hit it off and
became a circle of friends the original
pitch for will and grace was actually
about three couples only one of which
was a gay man living with a straight
woman nbc president warren littlefield
suggested that the show was too busy and
should just focus on this storyline and
relationship ditching the others and
that wasn't the only major change leslie
jordan's role as the socialite and karen
walker frenemy beverly wesley was
originally written for an actress and
not just any actress but dynasty vet
joan collins leslie jordan has claimed
that collins turned down the role
because of a single scene in which
another actor was to rip her wig off but
i'm sad to say we do not have
authoritative independent confirmation
on this great anecdote yay penguins
please i mean that is absurd there is no
such thing as a gay penguin well well
well
will grace debuted in september of 1998
in april of 1997 ellen degeneres
publicly came out as gay and over the
following season of tv her abc sitcom
had someone dipped in the ratings this
caused some nervousness over at nbc
about whether or not audiences would
accept will and grace a show featuring
multiple gay lead characters ultimately
co-creator david cohan has said that he
thinks the precedent set by ellen and
the remaining buzz around her decision
to go public and her tv show helped will
and grace make it to air the show's
enduring popularity has been widely
credited with helping to improve public
opinion about the lgbtq plus community
and gay rights issues more broadly the
smithsonian has items from the series in
its lgbtq plus history collection and
curator dwight blocker bowers praised
the show as using comedy to familiarize
a mainstream audience with gay culture
president joe biden also credited the
show with educating the american public
about issues of concern to the gay
community during a 2012 appearance on
meet the press you may or may not know
this but my business associate benji and
i have come to a parting of the waves
and i thought you two would last forever
you were definitely the most
stable in the closet short tall black
white young old disgusting hot couple i
know that title by the way comes from a
book about jewish philosophy called i
and thou by martin buber he writes that
people need both the will to seek out
the truth or the eternal and the grace
to receive it and here you thought it
was just because those are the
characters first names tv it's never
that simple
what do you want to start with
32 all right here's the 32
all right
oh okay
curb your enthusiasm started life way
back in 1999 as a one-off larry david
comedy special for hbo the project was
conceived as an actual non-fiction film
in which documentarian robert b weed who
had made a few notable profiles of
comedians including wc fields mort saul
and lenny bruce would follow veteran
stand up larry david around the comedy
club as he prepped new material for an
hbo special after weed had started
shooting footage of david the concept
shifted into a mockumentary it still
followed larry david as he prepped for
an hbo special but fictionalized the
scenarios this time concluding with the
seinfeld co-creator deciding to not do
the comedy special at all and backing
out of the project
unlike the series in this original curb
special the characters were all aware of
the presence of the camera and that they
were being filmed the original special
was so realistic old florida friends of
actor cheryl hines believed it was true
and got upset with her for not inviting
them to her wedding to larry david she
was still working as a personal
assistant for rob reiner's family at
this point so
that would have been big news even after
curb shifted to an entirely fictional tv
sitcom robert weed stayed on board he
directed most of the show's first five
seasons and helped to define its
approach and comedic voice
by the way before we get into that are
you aware that you have a wobbly table
here
look at this look at this table it's
unbelievable
i don't know how you can go to bed at
night yeah it doesn't bother me
if all tables in your house wobbled you
could live like that you could live in a
wobble house we need to talk about ted
we need to talk about everything that
just happened here what famously no
dialogue is ever written out for the
show larry david starts with a rough
outline for an episode totaling about
seven or eight pages and the actors fill
in the details all on their own before
the cameras go on the performers don't
even try at living real dialogue they
just say blah blah blah while blocking
out the scene then begin the improv once
the cameras are turned on the concern is
that they'd say something funny in
rehearsal but then be unable to recreate
the spontaneity of the moment when
everything is actually being recorded
for posterity
david has said that his fictional
persona is basically the real him but if
he lived completely untethered in a
world without consequences or rules so
in a way the curb version presents his
idealized most fully realized self and
that may not be entirely healthy but
it's certainly been creatively fruitful
how did you get in here i have my own
keys you forgot to change the locks okay
i want that key back okay and you need
to go this is not a college dormitory
where you can visit years later and
catch up on things we don't have alumni
weekends okay i never should have sold
this house to you you're destroying it
and you're certainly destroying this
plan okay curb has been nominated for 47
prime time emmy awards including
outstanding comedy series for each of
its first 10 seasons that means it holds
the most nominations in that category
without a win which is pretty pretty
pretty good that's great so the other
449 families live in fear is that what
we're saying i mean come on where's your
decent
what the hell just fell off your face
one of this guy's eyebrows just fell in
the bowl of candy beans i always carry a
spare well i hope you also carry a spare
bowl of candy beans arrested development
first ran on fox from 2003 to 2006
before finishing off its run many years
later on netflix but those first three
fox seasons arrived at a time when a
number of comedy shows were
experimenting with new more modern
feeling styles and formats arrested
development's laugh track free single
camera aesthetic filmed handheld like a
documentary but without the characters
knowing they're on camera influenced the
bevy of later shows from community to
it's always sunny in philadelphia and
beyond a number of other series also
borrowed arrested development's frequent
use of running jokes and cutaway gags 30
rock i'm looking in your direction when
george senior was in charge he had a
habit of shooting down any idea michael
came up with in sudden valley just sort
of implies that something awful could
happen all of a sudden you know plus
it's on a hill what are you taking
stupid pills come on save us some money
this was a management tool it was
producer slash narrator ron howard's
original idea to do a single camera
comedy series with handheld cameras a
concept inspired by the then surging
popularity of reality shows imagine tv
brought in a few writers and creatives
to workshop the idea including mitch
hurwitz who suggested a story based on
corporate accounting scandals remember
that whole enron thing back in 2001
kinda like that
howard served as the initial narrator
for the pilot but was intended only as a
place filler when the team heard how
well his audio blended in with the tone
of the rest of the show though they
decided to keep him on also he's their
boss so
you know lucille austero had just
returned from a month-long stay at a
facility that specialized in the
treatment of vertigo having ron howard
around was also clutch in convincing
liza minnelli to join the ensemble as
supporting character lucille ii the duo
without a lifelong friendship dating
back to manelli babysitting a young
ronnie howard when she was still a
teenager you can google that one it's
100 true in mitch herwitz's original
scripts the now iconic character tobias
was just a small supporting role it was
only after david cross was on set
hanging out with the ensemble so well
that hurwitz decided to expand the role
into a series regular at the time fox
president gail berman had a strict
policy against any actors on the
network's comedy shows having a mustache
she also had strict and surprisingly
specific rules against anyone wearing
ball caps or puffy sleeves on air
okay cross had to fight to keep tobias
mustache which berman agreed to so long
as it never got too bushy
huh so no one likes a bushy mustache i
guess it's not funny i like him could
you come get me
i have to stay here and answer the phone
okay could someone come and get me
please ryan
michael you should stay home and rest
there's no toilet paper here could ryan
tell ryan to bring toilet paper could
you tell him that can you hop i tried
hopping kevin and i bumped my elbow
against the wall the office the uk
version of the office ran for just two
short seasons 14 total episodes in the
early 2000s but the jaded snarky series
about horrible boss david brent was a
global smash hit making a stateside
remake almost inevitable but nbc didn't
just pluck some rando out of obscurity
to bring the exciting world of paper
sales to u.s televisions they tapped
greg daniels who resume already included
writing stints on saturday night live
the simpsons and seinfeld
all the best s shows plus he co-created
fox's king of the hill he could have
just rested on those impressive wilds
but nay daniels developed the us version
of the office served as the showrunner
for the first four seasons and then left
to make yet another hit show parks and
recreation he did come back for the
final year of the office though because
i guess he's sentimental at heart abc
okay and that stands for airway
breathing and circulation okay you know
what that could be a little confusing
because in sales abc means always be
closing this is a farce i should be
teaching this course shut it shut it we
found ourselves on the
less prepared side of things when
stanley had his
when his heart went berserk as an odd to
the uk series by the way the dunder
mifflin address is listed as 1725 slow
avenue there's no real slow avenue in
scranton that's the english town where
the original show was set it's britain's
version of scranton pennsylvania the
first team of office writers included
daniels his future parks and rec partner
mike shure and three of the show's most
recognizable on-screen co-stars mindy
kaling who played kelly kapoor b.j novak
who co-starred as ryan the intern and
paul lieberstein aka toby from hr mike
shurer also appeared on camera though in
a smaller supporting role that's him as
dwight schrutes to kill your cousin mose
with 24 total episodes credited to her
kaling is the most prolific office
writer of all time that's just about 1 8
of all the episodes put together the
rain is over and gone
the time of singing has come
and the voice of the turtle dove is
heard in our land bj novak was cast
right away as ryan but the rest of the
ensemble went through numerous changes
before everything felt right saul
goodman himself bob odenkirk was very
close to signing on as michael scott
before steve carell's schedule freed up
angela kinsey originally auditioned to
play pam beasley seth rogan was strongly
considered for the role of dwight
schrute and adam scott auditioned to
play jim halper to prepare to play gym
after john krasinski toured around
scranton pa and spoke with a number of
employees at various paper companies
actual footage that krasinski shot on
his trip appears in the opening credits
i'm guessing he also practiced that
exasperated look into camera move it had
to become muscle memory at some point
right
david
david
david i'm here
i'm sorry for not responding to like one
tax david shit's creek the first
canadian series on our list comes from
father-son team eugene and dan levy who
co-created the show and co-star as
johnny and david rose the show was
initially a co-production with the pop
tv american cable network but didn't
really find a us audience until it hit
netflix after its third season it
sometimes takes us a little while to
catch up but we get there dan levy came
up with the idea for the show after
watching reality tv and specifically
thinking about how one of those infamous
wealthy kardashian-esque families would
survive if they suddenly found
themselves with no money the levies were
also inspired by a true story about
actress kim basinger purchasing the town
of brazleton georgia for 20 million
dollars in 1989.
in truth kim didn't technically buy a
whole town she and some partners bought
a bunch of buildings and property in the
area which he hoped to turn into a film
and recording studio plus a tourist
destination well those plans didn't pan
out and basically irena partners resold
the property in 1995 but the idea stuck
with the levees and inspired a story
about the down and out rose family
moving to a rural town they purchased on
a whim alexis what the hell is the
matter with you
okay
stavros is flying in to get me and i'm
going to go live with him for a little
bit
well that is not happening and i am
appalled that my baby girl has turned
into a selfish duplicitous horror oh
hello the title came from eugene levy
though it very nearly got changed on
routes of the screen the canadian
broadcast company which co-produced the
show along with pop tv worried that the
title was too vulgar to put on the air
the levy sent them excerpts from several
phone books proving that
[ __ ] with the sea and extra t is in fact
a real last name that lots of people
actually have moira rose's iconic
wardrobe and personal style were based
on designer daphne guinness heiress to
the guinness stout fortune who became a
particular inspiration for star
catherine o'hara as the character moira
o'hara wore over a hundred wigs during
the course of the show each of which she
and her personal hair stylist and soros
selected annie murphy's performance as
alexis in particular her frequent use of
vocal fry was also inspired by watching
people on reality tv shows to this day
alex is saying ew david remains one of
the most frequently quoted lines from
the show but she actually only utters
this specific expression three times
total over the course of the entire six
seasons
why is it dark
there's like a witch's house in here
david shush get off my bed ouch david
ouch david
shut the curtains alexis says just david
without the ew over 224 times in just
the first five seasons so you know if
any of you are working on your
impressions it's just something to
remember or you could put down three or
four months rent if you've been saving i
have been saving okay
hbo's insecure debuted on october 9 2016
and aired for five total seasons in 2017
it was selected by the afi as one of the
year's top 10 programs it has also
played host to a number of notable
filmmakers and directors behind the
camera including choreography legend
debbie allen queen and slim helmer
molina matsukis writer director tina
mabry actress carrie washington and all
around hollywood icon regina king
the show was co-created by issa rae and
daily chauvette larry wilmore inspired
by rey's landmark youtube series awkward
black girl this definitely makes her one
of the most successful former youtubers
in hollywood history alongside lily
singh beau burnham and really anyone
who's doing a pay-per-view boxing match
prior to insecure rey had been
developing a very different series
called i hate l.a dudes that was going
to be about a single woman dating
various image obsessed guys in hollywood
ray pitched that show to shonda rhimes
and her business partner betsy beers but
it didn't end up coming together she
later said that her heart wasn't fully
into the l.a dudes concept and the
experience led her to develop the more
personal and authentic insecure
and i do mean authentic yvonne orgy's
character molly carter is not only based
on issa rae's real best friend they even
share the same name the creators work
with a number of cultural consultants as
well to ensure maximum on-screen
authenticity recording artist solange
serves as musical consultant and
frequently showcases up-and-coming
artists on the soundtrack costume
designer shiana torini collaborates with
a number of prominent black designers
when dressing the characters including
blk mkt vintage and no seso this is all
done with purpose of course when you
work hard you play hard that's right
that's that 80 40 ratio right there
it's overlapped i know man okay y'all
hey i'm molly hello and i'm percocet
what are we doing
that's her name she's molly and i'm
drunk
ray said when introducing the series to
the television critics association that
the goal was to make everyday black life
relatable as she put it this is about
regular people living life
wow um this doesn't happen very often
does it no
no
no
it's quite rare
i hate myself
like so many great british shows fleabag
became a massive global success despite
running for just a handful of episodes
across two brief seasons but don't worry
creator and star phoebe waller bridge
has assured us the show will never ever
return that's it folks i guess time for
us to move on the fleabag tv series was
adapted from waller bridge's one woman
show which ran at the 2013 edinburgh
fringe festival and even picked up a
fringe first award that show in turn was
inspired by a dare from a friend who
would challenge phoebe to perform a
10-minute block on a storytelling and
comedy show as an original character
that character is never identified on
screen by name as fleabag the name just
appears as a title and in the credits it
was actually a family nickname for
waller bridge when she was a kid i guess
someone else in the neighborhood was
already champ and whatever else she used
it for the play as a way of comparing
the character to a fleabag motel it
looks okay on the outside but once you
get in the rooms and you start looking
around you realize it's a total mess
i've been there the show inspired a
french remake from creator gene harry
known as moosh mouche i failed french in
high school which translates to english
simply as fly
camille cotton stars in that version and
the action is reset in paris but
otherwise the story lines are pretty
similar i thought you'd be in prison by
though oh well keep trying but they just
won't have me
i'm sorry about your eye oh that's okay
gives me some edge i've told them some
heroic [ __ ] bless you sandy thank
you the much-loved season two hot priest
role was written specifically for actor
andrew scott whom waller bridge had
first worked with nearly a decade before
in a play at the soho theater if scott
had said no there's a good chance
fleabag season two would have never
happened waller bridge has said she's
not sure she could have pulled those
scenes off with another actor all i can
say is thank goodness that timing worked
out fleabag season 2 won four emmys
including outstanding comedy series lead
actress in a comedy series writing in a
comedy series both of those went to
phoebe waller bridge and harry bradbeer
picked up a prize for his directive plus
we should highlight the show's memorable
score phoebe's sister isabelle waller
bridge composed all the music and this
isn't just nepotism folks she's
classically trained having studied music
at edinburgh university king's college
london and the royal academy of music
i have never been to any of those places
and i can't play music so my hat's off
to the entire waller bridge family well
that's it for today what we're not doing
all 296 shows from the book i guess
that's it for today and we've given you
so many great memorable and downright
important tv shows to watch that you
probably have a queue that's a mile long
there's not even going to be room for
you to watch movies at this point just
clear out a few weeks i'm sure your boss
is gonna understand and don't forget you
can find so many more tv comedies that
weren't even mentioned here in rotten
tomatoes the ultimate binge guide book a
bingeable bucket list of all the shows
you need to see before you die coming
november with pre-orders open now and
once you're done benching all those
shows come on back here for more rt
essentials and i'm sure we'll find
something else to overload you with
that's what we do for rotten tomatoes
[Music]
you